-Oh, it's so good
to be out of my house.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, with a full audience.
How's that feel? Come on.
-Oh, my God, it feels so good.
I didn't know how much
I needed it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah. Right? We need it.
I want to get into the book,
but I have a bigger thing
I want to talk to you about.
This is very exciting for me
because I --
This is real.
-Mm-hmm.
Oh, we're going in.
-We're going to go in.
[ Laughter ]
You had an experience
with a UFO.
-Yes, I did.
I did. Yes.
-Walk me through it.
Did you know that you were going
to have this experience?
-I did not know,
as many people don't.
[ Laughter ]
But, yeah, so I am a huge alien,
paranormal conspiracist.
It's my hobby.
I love that more than anything
else in the world.
And I was just -- I was
in the middle of Hollywood
and I was walking down
Santa Monica Boulevard.
-Nighttime, daytime?
-Daytime.
Middle of the day.
-Daytime UFO?
-Daytime. Daytime UFO, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And so I just saw this thing
hovering in the sky
and I remember looking up
thinking like,
"This can't be real." Like, "I
want this too much." You know?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You're like, "Yeah, come on."
-So I whipped out my camera
and it was like a cylinder shape
and it was not moving
with the wind.
It was moving kind of like --
almost like a dog's tail.
Just like this, just hovering,
several hundred feet above me.
-This is a UFO.
So, say that's a UFO.
-Okay, I'm trying to do this --
This is gonna look phallic.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright.
-Basically like this.
-So it's that?
-Yeah. Am I turning you on?
[ Laughter ]
-But, wait, so it's not
this way?
-It was not this way. No, no.
It was --
[ Laughter ]
-Sorry, get your mind
out of the --
-It was happy to see me.
[ Laughter ]
-We're talking about UFOs here.
-Yeah.
-So it's like almost
missile-like.
-Missile -- yes, that's a great
way of putting it, yeah.
And it was very --
it wasn't a balloon
because it was very
bottom-heavy, like myself.
[ Laughter ]
-Give me that. Give me that.
-Yeah, so I caught a video of it
and, yeah, I think we have it.
-Chris brought the video.
This is unbelievable.
This is real footage of
Chris Colfer's UFO sighting.
Take a look at this.
[ Laughter ]
-I see it.
-There it is.
Wait. I see this.
-I mean --
Very creepy.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. So I think -- Yeah.
[ Applause ]
Thank you. Yeah.
-That's wild that you saw it,
and you thought enough
to bring your phone out.
-Right, right. And I sent it
to everyone I knew and, like,
you would have thought
I won like a Pulitzer,
because everyone was like,
"Oh, Chris, congratulations.
You've been working for this
for so long."
[ Laughter ]
-It finally happened!
-God has a plan. God has a plan.
[ Laughter ]
-"God has a plan."
And I believe it.
I believe it was a UFO.
I want to talk about your book,
"A Tale of Sorcery."
This is your 18th book.
-Mm-hmm.
-Congrats on these.
How much time --
They take up all of your --
This is years of work.
-Yeah.
-And do you have, like,
deadlines you have to get to?
-Lot of deadlines, yeah.
And yeah, no, it is
a lot of work
and it requires so much
self-discipline.
And I think --
I'm wrapping up --
It's a trilogy,
and I'm wrapping up the trilogy,
and I think I'm ending it
on a nice spot.
So I think I'm going to
take a little bit of a break
from writing and just,
you know, let the muscle
kind of relax a little bit.
And also, like,
this weird thing happened.
I was at a bar,
and this man came over
and just started
flirting with me.
Like aggressively flirting with
me and offered to get me a drink
and all this stuff,
and I politely declined
because I'm taken and he was
like, "Oh, that's okay.
By the way, I loved your books
when I was a kid."
[ Laughter ]
And I said, I said,
"Okay, that's not possible
because the first one came out
nine years ago
and that would have made you --"
and he goes, "11."
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-And it was really traumatic,
so I think I'm going to
take a little break.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah.
-That spooked you.
You go, "That's it. I'm done.
I got to take a little break."
I understand. I understand.
-Yeah, yeah.
-But these are great books.
I mean, you got to be --
You have to be proud of
what you've done.
-Oh, thank you. Yeah, I am.
And I know, like,
a lot of people told me
I could never do this
because of who and what I was.
So I am very proud that
I'm able to show kids
that someone like us,
someone like me can do it,
and I'm really proud of
how many other kids
I've inspired to write,
because I know how therapeutic
writing was for me growing up,
and it was a constant escape
whenever you needed one.
So, yeah, I'm really happy
I'm encouraging kids
to put pen to paper.
-On behalf of all the parents,
thanks for doing all this stuff.
We love these books.
-Oh, thank you so much.
-Read!
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Get your kids
out there reading.
Chris Colfer, everybody!
"A Tale of Sorcery"
is available now.
It's out today.